[Music]
we haven't even seen keanu reeves in the
long awaited matrix sequel in john wick
4 and 5 so far
and yet the much sought after actor has
already been signed up for two more
projects
we're talking about the comic adaption
berserker in which he will not only play
the leading actor and producer but
also the writer together with comic
author matt ken reeves conceived the
storyline and published it as a comic
for the first time
earlier this month the ominous title of
the work is the spelling of the word
berserker just like the main character
of the story who bears the same name
or rather the nickname beam b is an
immortal warrior who is condemned to
find his way through the world's entire
history
for all eternity he has been doing this
for almost 80
000 years which gets quite exhausting in
the long run obviously
however a time of redemption seems to be
inside when the u.s government hires the
warrior to win battles for them that are
too risky for
others the prize they have to find out
everything about his mysterious
existence and provide him with the
answer on how to end it all after
so many years definitely sounds like a
whole lot of fun in havoc
however there's also a second project
planned for berserker and that is an
anime series of the same name this is
supposed to offer
a different take on the comics universe
and possibly even establish
a whole new main character unfortunately
there is no information about a release
date for the two netflix projects
but keanu reeves should have enough to
do with john wick chapter 4 and 5 for
the
time being anyway the john wick series
is usually associated with a rainy night
in new york city
and a storyline that takes the
protagonist to all corners of the world
the upcoming john wick chapter 4 will be
no different quite the opposite
as collider magazine found out the main
settings of the fourth part are berlin
and paris with additional trips to new
york city and japan
john wick and keanu reeves are at least
very familiar with berlin
because while the baba yaga has business
matters to take care of the german
capital
keanu also lived there for a few months
during the shooting of matrix iv
what is entirely new about john wake
four and five is that creator derek
colstad will
no longer be part of it michael finch
has already been taking over his duties
for several months and he's in complete
charge of the screenplay
at the very least the well-known face
will once again take the director's
chair namely director
chad stehalski furthermore there is to
announce that the previously planned
double shooting of parks 405
is now history instead john week 4 will
be shot this summer while john wick 5
will be shot at a much later date
perhaps due to the pandemic
fans shouldn't worry too much about part
5 though because according to our
sources the film
is still on track john wick's presumed
vengeance after the end of part 3 can
hopefully seen
in may 2022
the quality of the resident evil movies
released so far is debatable
either you celebrate the action-packed
blockbusters or you miss the horror
factor and the thematic relevance to the
movie game originals director johannes
roberts has now
announced the official title of the
reboot which is based on the two highly
praised first parts of the video game
franchise to be resident evil
welcome to raccoon city in terms of
content the new project will finally put
the past films and the milo djokovic
behind
and return to its origins director
roberts who has been in the director's
chair for 47 meters down and the
strangers too amongst other projects
seems best suited for the job we can
only hope that the 44 year old succeeds
in making a fresh start and that he'll
be able to recreate the dark rainy
atmosphere of the two video games on
film
the international release date for
resident evil welcome to raccoon city is
scheduled for september 3rd
2021 as netflix announced on twitter
last monday a total of seven new actors
have been cast for the upcoming second
season of the witcher
the two most prominent characters named
dixtra and reigns will be portrayed by
graham mcdavish and chris fulton
while the clever dixtra act as the head
of the redanian intelligence
the powerful mage rings presumably
targets gerald's foster daughter siri
and the witcher himself
other new additions include the
priestess in the neck played by ajo
ando philippa eilhardt played by cassie
claire as well as fenn
code ringer and balliam the biggest
thrill of anticipation for fans will
probably come from the aforementioned
chris faultenaz ruins who's undoubtedly
one of the sorcerer's most unpleasant
adversaries in the book series
the mage is often considered perhaps not
to be the most powerful yet the most
brutal and sadistic villain he usually
operates on behalf of vilgeforce who in
turn has a good chance of becoming
gerald's main antagonist over the course
of the series
unfortunately there is no news as of yet
as to when season 2 of the acclaimed
netflix series will be released but
until then
fans can look forward to the animated
film the witcher nightmare of the wolf
first
between 1995 and 2002 pierce bros
enacted four times as the world famous
mi6 agent james bond surprisingly for
many fans it has now been announced that
we will soon be seeing the 67 year old
in front of the camera as dwayne
johnson's adversary in the upcoming
black adam after many years of silence
around the bond actor he will now
celebrate his comeback into the highly
anticipated a-list films with the role
of magician dr
fate in the dc universe his character dr
feint has been established in the comics
since 1940
and bears the civil name camp nelson
from an early age the superhero acquired
his magical powers from the old wizard
naboo
he taught nelson everything he needed to
know about the world of magic and gave
him two powerful artifacts
a distinctive golden helmet and the
amulet of anubis
both objects act as sort of catalyst for
nelson's powers and increases strength
many times over so now we will see dr
fade as black adam's antagonist
though this doesn't mean at all that dr
fate is evil since in the comics he's
considered to be a protector of humanity
from threats of supernatural nature thus
many fans are speculating that
both of them will fight each other in
the course of the movie but
ultimately will have to face a much
greater force and will be compelled to
team up
therefore it's quite fitting that
production is slowly gearing up and
hopefully we'll get first pictures from
the set in the next few
months a release date for black adam has
unfortunately
not yet been announced what do you think
about the rather unexpected casting of
pierce brosnan do you think he will
harmonize with rain johnson in front of
the camera or would you have preferred a
completely
different dc character for the upcoming
black adam movie
feel free to write us in the comments
next year it's happening
the flash with ezra miller and michael
keaton will hit theaters
at least that's what many fans think but
as keaton revealed in an interview with
deadline it could be a tight squeeze for
his batman appearance
he stated that he's very busy right now
and that he has already called the
executives of the flash to ask for their
understanding regarding any scheduling
conflicts on keaton's part
he's currently very involved in his
current project and has not yet had time
to strike a deal with the producers
behind the flash
besides he expressed great concern about
the pandemic and getting infected so
he is always making his work dependent
on the current situation
the whole thing seems anything but
pleasant now after all many fans are
eagerly looking forward to the return of
the batman actor announced at the end of
last year
regardless there's also distinctly
better news about the flash because the
role of the superhero father doctor
henry allen has been recast
billy crudup who was originally planned
for the role is now succeeded by
the morning show actor ron livingston
incidentally livingston shares his
parental role with maribel verdu who
embodies the mother of the fastest man
in the world it is a known fact that the
flash will be shot this year although
at present it can only be assumed how
the matter with michael keaton will be
resolved
the flash is expected to be released in
theaters on november 3rd
2022 it seems as though disney plus is
currently on a similar path as
competitor provider hbo max one reason
for this is an announcement by disney
which revealed the release of black
widow and cruella via video on demand
the two new titles will be available as
vip titles on the movie company's own
streaming service at the same time
as the theatrical release however users
should refrain from getting too excited
at this point because similar to mulan
they will have to pay an additional fee
which can quickly add up to
20 euros black widow will now be the
first marvel film to be released
simultaneously on disney plus and in
theaters
the dane has been set for july 9th
whereas you can already watch crella on
may 28th
on the other hand you will be able to
watch the latest pixar production
luca on disney plus without paying a vip
fee
starting on june 18 2021
[Music]
you